But in my brain I had to stop and start over.
Okay.
[inaudible]
wants to sound rises.
Drugs this out to clear meal
push.
Come to shove and throw some money on the table.
Cover last time stuff and got the soul of a hall.
Got the hot of a loan,
the man
fucking thing.
So but best that I can
just lack of nail them to the slaughter.
The hose to the bottom of the walnut drank.
It is
scared little ball with a real live one.
Hell of a man.
Fall in love in a Java.
Strangers.
These the average things love up in the heavens but here on earth he must've
lost Ark Badge.
High Bleed again.
Still out.
Same to see if someone had seen him be get Kyle [inaudible] with them.
Skate Amnon that you bought off.
You got the mind of a lap.
The solo solar archer
breaking down and that's Trulia unfolds
fighting for survival and sacrificial.
Rare new raffle gurus.
Government issue.
Harmful of stone got a knob that's about fatigue and
fucking posting up on Twitter's gone.
Sweet.
My name
cause the owl gone stupid.
The Owl Guy Lazy.
It was spiraling.
Bernie in the idolized crazy Mattawan go to heaven,
but everyone's afraid to die.
If God is real borough religions out,
just one
boss said lower sandwiches,
higher body.
You got to [inaudible].
You
said one big fight.
Aw Man.
That's your really,
it was horrible.
No,
that was great.
Terrible.
No,
it was a real moment,
man.
No,
I let my mind get away from me on that one.
That's one I shouldn't answer the phone.
I was gonna lose.